the ability of pythons allows you to use
broadcasting operations and more
generally the great flexibility of the
Python numpy programming language is I
think both our strength as well as a
weakness of the programming language I
think it's a strength because the great
expressivity of the language to create
flexibility of the language lets you get
a lot done you know with even just a
single line of code but there's also a
weakness because with broadcasting and
this great amount of flexibility
sometimes is possible we can introduce
very subtle bugs a very strange-looking
bugs if you aren't familiar with all of
the intricacies of how broadcasting and
how features like broadcasting work for
example if you take a column vector and
add it to a row vector you might expect
it to throw up a you know dimension
mismatch or type error or something
but you might actually get back a matrix
is the sum of a row vector and a column
vector so there is an internal logic to
these strange effects of Python but you
are familiar with Python now I've seen
some students have very strange very
hard to find bugs so what I want to do
in this video is share view a couple of
tips and tricks that have been very
useful for me to eliminate or simplify
and eliminate all the strange looking
both in my own code and I hope that with
these tips and tricks you also be able
to much more easily write bug free
Python in my code to illustrate one of
the less intuitive effects of Python
numpy especially how you construct
vectors in Python numpy let me do a
quick demo let's say I set a equals NP
dot random dot R and n 5 so this creates
a five random Gaussian there vols
stored in an array a and so let's print
a and now it turns out that the shape of
a when you do this is this 5 kamar on
structure and so this is called a rank 1
array in Python and it's neither a row
vector in nor a column vector and this
leads it has some 13 Allah teaches
effects over
I print a transpose it ends up looking
the same as a so a and a transpose and
you're looking the same and if I print
the inner product between a and a
transpose here you might think a times a
transpose is maybe the outer product
should give you a matrix maybe but if I
do that use then get back a number so
what I would recommend is that when
you're coding neural networks that you
just not use data structures where the
shape is this you know five comma n
comma ranked one array instead if you
set a to be from this five point one
then this commits a to be five by one
column vector and whereas previously a
and a transpose look the same review now
print a transpose now a transpose is a
row vector notice one subtle difference
on in this data structure there are two
square brackets when you print a
transpose whereas previously there was
one square bracket so that's the
difference between a this is really a
one by five matrix versus a one of these
are rank one arrays and if you print
save these product between a and a
transpose then this gives you the outer
product of a vector R and so the ultra
profitable vector gives you a matrix so
let's look in greater detail at what we
just saw here the first command that we
ran just now was this and this created a
data structure where a dot shape was
this a funny thing v comma and so this
is called a rank one array and this is a
very funny data structure it doesn't
behave consistently as either a row
vector nor a column vector which makes
some of this effects non-intuitive so
what I'm going to recommend um is that
when you are doing your program
exercises or in fact when you're
implementing which is regression on your
networks that you just do not use these
rank one arrays instead if every time
you create an array you commit to making
either a column vector so this crazy 501
vector or commit to making a row vector
then the behavior of your vectors will
may be easier to understand so in this
case a dot shape is going to be equal to
5 comma 1 and so this behaves a lot like
they or that this is a column vector and
that's why you might you can think of
this as a 5 by 1 matrix or as a column
vector and here a dot shape is going to
be 1 comma 5 and this behaves
consistently as a row vector so when you
need a vector I would say either use
this or this but not a Rank 1 array one
more thing that I do a lot to my code is
if I'm not entirely sure what's the
dimension of one of my vectors are often
throw in an assertion statement like
this to make sure in this case that this
is a five by one vector so this is a
column vector these assertions are
really inexpensive to execute and they
also help to serve as documentation for
your code so don't hesitate to throw an
assertion statements like this one if
you like it and then finally if for some
reason you do end up with a rank one
array you can reshape this a equals a
dot reshape into say a five by one array
or one by five arrays so that it behaves
more consistently as either a column
vector or row vector so sometimes seen
students and that was very hard to track
down bugs because of other non-intuitive
effects of rank one arrays by
eliminating rank one of rays on my own
code I think my code became simpler and
I did not actually find it restrictive
in terms of things like an expressing
code to just never use a rank one array
and so takeaways are to simplify your
code
don't use rank one with Ray's always use
either n by one matrices basically
column vectors or one by n matrices or
basically row vectors feel free to toss
a lot of assertion statements so
double-check the dimensions or matrices
and rays and also you know don't be shy
about calling the reshape operation to
make sure that your matrices or your
vectors are the dimension
you needed to be so that I hope that
this set of suggestions helps you to
eliminate a cause of bugs that they're
from from from Python code and makes the
program exercise easier to complete